the Curiosity rover is truly an
interplanetary Swiss Army knife equipped
with a slew of onboard instruments for
investigating the Red Planet the primary
mission was two years so we're into a
couple extended missions now yeah we
don't know exactly how long it'll keep
going we never know can't predict that
things are still going great on the
mission we're discovering new rock units
every day so we hope for several more
years to go
the rover has been slowly meandering
around Mars ever since it landed in 2012
using specialized instruments to examine
the surface perform experiments and even
find time to take a selfie these
instruments have led to some historic
discoveries in 2015
atmospheric greetings from the rover
suggested that Mars at one point
experienced a vigorous loss of
atmosphere causing its ancient oceans to
evaporate and last year curiosity
detected organic matter and sediment
samples taken from Gale Crater since
2012 the rover has been traversing the
154 km/h our senses want to know whether
Gale Crater was once completely filled
with sediment did it disappear over time
due to erosion or was the crater never
filled at all Gale Crater that the rover
is exploring in is five kilometers deep
Mount sharp is a five kilometre tall
mountain inside of that crater one of
the things that happens as you vary
sediments on the earth or any other
planet is that you increasingly compact
those sediments and lose the porosity
and those sediments will get denser and
denser and denser as you bury them to
greater depth the key to answering this
question lies in gravimetry the precise
measurement of gravitational fields
these fields are correlated with density
variations in the crust
unfortunately the rover wasn't equipped
with instruments designed to detect
these changes to get around this
researchers recalibrated curiosity's
accelerometers instruments normally used
for navigation to measure the changes in
gravitational acceleration as the rover
climbs the base of Mount sharp
you know I kind of realized one day that
gravity is just an acceleration and we
have accelerometers onboard and got kind
of curious about how good those
accelerometers were and and slowly began
to figure out calibration for that data
to the point where we had a precision
that was meaningful for understanding
the geology at the landing site after
five years of measurements scientists
were able to determine the density of
Gale Crater sedimentary rocks well in
this case one of the interesting things
is that the density was surprisingly low
even for sedimentary rocks which tend to
be lower density than say a lava right
the surprisingly low density tells us
that these sediments were likely never
buried to the full depth of Gale Crater
which would be five kilometers as the
mission rolls on researchers would like
to use curiosity's accelerometers for
another purpose to measure Mars as
seismic signals in hopes of detecting
Mars quake what we kind of show is that
they're not in great seismometers so we
would need either a pretty large
earthquake or a pretty nearby earthquake
to detect it at least in the
measurements that we're currently making
and while it's unlikely that curiosity
will detect a Mars quake the insight
Lander is designed to do just that
researchers would also like to solve the
mystery of how Mount sharp came to be
yes a mount sharp kind of continues to
be a puzzle we don't know especially for
the upper layers of the mountain how
that formed the whole thing is a stack
of layers and the layers are all tilted
outwards so it's almost like a haystack
in the middle of this five kilometer
deep crater so especially for those
upper units they may have kind of formed
as a free-standing haystack
rather than having filled the crater
entirely
but that's just a theory so we'll have
to get up there and figure it out
[Music]